I've been on this kick forever and it
really does matter the amount of people
I just DM who I don't even know and just
say keep going love what you're doing
give encouragement the amount of friends
and acquaintances I just check in on
randomly just text and say love you hope
you're well what's cooking you never
know when you perfectly time your text
when somebody needs you so so so bad
when the sirens are going off in their
life and you can be the person that
actually triggers A New Perspective or
uh extra boost or it might not even be
that serious it's just giving somebody a
smile
um that needed one that day not that
they were having a bad day they're just
having a normal day and a smile just
made it better friends acquaintances
former classmates former teammates
former co-workers people you admire on
social DM and text say what's up say
what's up